get started first a few words about the
required work in this course there is a
take home midterm examination
this is going to be arranged primarily
for my personal convenience I mean by
that is that on November 18th I will not
be in class because I have to go to a
conference in California so it seemed to
me that that week would be a good week
for you to write your your take-home
midterm examination which means that the
topic or choice of topics will be handed
out probably only on the 16th and you'll
be given a week to to compose a response
and that would make the response do the
following a tuesday which i think is the
22nd 23rd that is also of course just
before thanksgiving but since you'll be
able to submit it by email if you don't
have a hard copy in class for those of
you who believe thanksgiving should be a
you know a week or 10 days all adei in
Guatemala or something you know we can
accommodate that with respect to the to
the to brief papers the teaching
assistants in this course section you
know supervisors they are going to
select topics and they are going to
assign these at the to fit their
personal schedules when they want to
read and evaluate these topics but the
second paper will be due at the very end
of the course more or less at the time
of the last lecture then there will be a
take home final examination which will
be due at the time
of what would be the regularly scheduled
date for the final examination the
reason for this is because grades are
expected to be submitted within a
certain amount of time after the final
examination it is not impossible to get
extensions on these things I have never
thought highly of professors who chopped
off limbs or do make other corporal
punishments for being late with work I
miss deadlines with distressing
frequency on the other hand it's
extremely wise unwise to put things off
of you unless you absolutely have to
simply because the build-up becomes too
great and also because there is a
psychological phenomenon that you might
not yet recognize because you have been
too diligent thus far in your careers
but it takes the form of a occurred of
anxiety so that you know as you get
nearer and aeri deadlines your anxiety
increases it goes up and you know now
you've missed the deadline your anxiety
increases it gets worse and worse and
then it goes down because you reach
assertive but what the hell phase and
and the paper that you thought was going
to be in two days late comes in three
months late and you know ride the curve
you know if you're going to to be a bit
late just be a bit late but you still
while you're still being driven by that
by that inner demon because it's going
to lose energy real fast once once
you've become hopelessly behind
all right now today I'm going to talk
about a topic that really is relevant to
several different chapters of the book
and is discussed explicitly in a in a
sort of historiographical essay that
occurs on pages 305 to 307 which you
have not yet had assigned and whatever
you get around reading the essay you
will see that it is a very summary form
of what I'm going to lecture on today
the reason I'm lecturing on it today is
because it picks up from the from what I
was talking about at the very end of
last lecture and that is the interesting
phenomenon of Buddhism and Christianity
taking root and having remarkable
success in these two empires we want to
use that term Rome and Han China and
having that success bridge the period of
the M of the decline and disappearance
of the Empire in other words it's not
something that that coincides with the
empire but rather something that grows
in its later stages raising the question
as of the of the degree to which the
political environment is a is an
operative factor here the example that
will arise more explicitly later on will
be with the rise of Islam Buddhism
Christianity and Islam I recognized as
the three great proselytizing religions
in the world and ones that sometimes
grow because of
you know political machinations of one
sort or another but are generally
thought to grow because of a kind of
natural a natural propensity of of the
faith to spread with sort of the
implicit notion that the faith appears
to be superior to whatever preceded it
in other words that it is seen as a as a
step up this is the bias of monotheists
they tend to to say you know one God is
better than two or is better than seven
or is a better than 150 there's no
demonstrative evidence that this is true
but there is a prejudice that
monotheists have and then of course you
have post religious people who feel that
if you've gotten it down to one presto
changing in that does zero and now we've
really don't reach the pinnacle of human
achievement now the question is why does
the religion grow and does a religion
grow in a way that is particular to the
fact that it is a religion or does the
growth of a religion represent simply
one example of a type of growth
phenomenon that could apply to other
things the answer you get to this
depends a lot on what you take to be
evidence and this is where I'm going to
belabor a certain point in this lecture
because I've written a book on
conversion to Islam in the medieval
period entitled conversion to Islam in
the medieval period and and I'm going to
lay out for you the thinking that went
behind that book because the argument of
the book is that the spread of Islam is
representative of the spread of all
sorts of things that it is not specific
to Islam it is not specific to a
religion it is not even specific to
intellectual or spiritual trend but it
is rather a sort of a special category
of the spread of all sorts of new things
and it really gets into the question of
how do things come to be known and how
do they spread the general topic us key
word in this is the word diffusion which
I've brought up in an earlier lecture
talking about the the problematic
aspects of diffusionless thinking and
how do you you know because something
appears here and it previously it
appeared over here is it plausible to
think that it's spread from here to
there now in the case of let us say
domestic pigs you have wild pigs occur
in many parts of the world you know
domestic pigs showing up in the Malay
Peninsula and in South Eastern Europe
pigs don't run very fast
they get tired if they will have to walk
a long way so the idea that somebody
domesticated pigs in Vietnam and then
trotted them off to Romania is not very
plausible and yet you have people who
will say well pigs were first
domesticated in a certain place and the
practice spread from there and so we say
ok that sort of diffusion theory is
somewhat weak because we have equally
plausible scenarios by which you would
have independent genesis of some new
tendency on the other hand if it was now
it was if it was known from
archaeological evidence that there were
no wild pigs in Romania now the only
place wild pigs ever occurred was
Malaysia then you would have to say well
yes those pigs must have been marched
off
to write it and you think well that sort
of bizarre except what we do know is
that all the chickens in the world come
from the Malay Peninsula that is where
the only place where the jungle fowl
from which the chicken as we know it
emerges as a domestic animal is that
that's where it exists as a wild as a
wild bird so it is possible to have
worldwide distribution from a single
point it's also possible to have
parallel invention or parallel
development and the the test for any
diffusion theory is of the plausibility
of scenario scenario a over scenario B
now in the case of a religion-- nobody
would argue that buddha lived in two
different places and that you had you
know Buddha in northern India and 500 BC
and another guy with the same name and
the same biography who lived in China in
100 BC same thing with Islam I mean
certain things start at certain places
so when you come to to the spread of
religion diffusion is an appropriate
keyword instead of being a problematic
keyword it has to spread from someplace
so what we're dealing here with is not
the the fact of not the question of
whether you have diffusion but more the
the mechanics by which this diffusion
occurred now there has been a too little
study of the history of the spread of
religions there are various reasons for
this I was once invited to speak at a
conference on traditional Christian
communities in the Islamic world and I
wrote back and I said I don't really
work on traditional Christian
communities said yeah but you work on on
conversion
and these are communities that
disappeared because the people became
Muslims so I went to the conference and
it was about this time of year and I
remember in Toronto at the Pontifical
Institute they're getting up in the
morning going to breakfast and you know
everyone's saying good morning father
good morning good morning brother good
morning father good morning father how
are you today father
how are you Reverend and I was saying
sanguine know who won the World Series
last night I said what's the world
series the study of conversion is often
or for a long time was considered the
preserve of people of faith usually
people of faith who were either on the
winning or the losing side and you had
an interesting pathology that accompany
that which was a kind of schizophrenia
in which you know if father so-and-so
was talking about the loss of Christian
souls to Islam he would usually be a
Marxist he would say the Muslims had
jobs they had money the handed out
goodies there was a tax break and those
people who left our faith left for
financial worldly health and then if you
talked about people who joined that
Christian community suddenly they switch
from being Marxist to being spiritualist
you know Jesus appeared in the heart of
the believer and called them to the
faith and the person who had not
previously been a Christian said I will
take Jesus as my savior and and convert
to Christianity so you had a problem
that people with deep faith commitments
had conflicted feelings when they talked
about change of religion you might think
this business of Jesus appearing in the
heart is it would be sort of silly but
I was once at a meeting of missionaries
in Tehran and there was a missionary
there a Protestant from Azerbaijan from
tempies he said that they had taken a
survey of all of the converts from Islam
to Christianity within the orbit of the
Protestant mission in Tabriz and they
just had to find out why they converted
to Christianity it turned out that every
single one of them had converted for the
same reason that Jesus had appeared in a
dream not a single one converted because
they they were hired to be a chauffeur
for the for the mission they just
happened to get that job otherwise and
I'm single one that had converted to be
a cook in the mission guesthouse it was
always that Jesus appeared in a dream
and of course you know I sort of raised
the question is he you know this is a
typical Islamic thing you know where you
know Mohammad or some saintly person
appears in a dream and thinking I was
making a important contribution and the
missionary said Jesus appears in all of
our dreams okay
I I guess I'm not quite on the same page
and so I dropped out of the debate quite
quickly but but it really has been the
case that that the assumption of people
joining the faith has been attributed to
let us say charisma to make it more
generally no more general and the
subject of people losing the faith
leaving the faith has often been
attributed to to worldly gain the
charisma is studied usually through the
lives of missionaries where the deeds of
a saintly person whether it's a
Christian missionary of the Protestant
ilk we have now whether it's a saint
from the early days of the Christian
Church whether it is a Buddhist bunk who
travels to faraway places or whether it
is a Muslim Sufi who goes off into the
wild the story of these these
missionaries to use a very general term
is often illuminated by instances of
charisma of miracles or you know saying
things that suddenly transform the world
for the listeners kind of sermon of the
mount ish type things and then the study
of the other side of the loss of the
faith is often involved with financial
issues you know changes in tax levels or
duties or jobs available things of that
sort
know
I don't believe that this is a competent
way to study religious change at least
it is not a way that I find persuasive
because it is anecdotal it is dependent
upon sources that are manifestly
doctored to serve a particular interest
and because it says very little about
about things that would affect the
ordinary people's lives it tends to to
deal with the elite particularly when
you something I who was the first person
to bring the Lotus Sutra to China say oh
it was so and so the great pilgrim he
brings a load of Sutra and you think
you're bringing the Lotus Sutra this
great Buddhist text to a country that is
mostly illiterate
well what who exactly read the Lotus
Sutra that's more important than who
brought it so I pursued a different line
and I said can you can you find a way of
determining when a particular family
converted from one religion to another
and for Iran in the Islamic period I
argued that this was possible because if
you know because we had very large
quantities of biographical material
about individuals the biographies said
nothing about conversion but the
biographies typically contained a
genealogy in the genealogy would say a
is the son of B as a son of C as a son
of D and because it was in Iran where
the language of Islam was Arabic but the
Lang of the native language was Persian
you would find genealogies that would go
Arabic Nate's the son of Arabic name the
son of Arabic name the son of Persian
name with this being a variable number
of generations
you didn't have any names past this
typically you would just go back to one
Persian name as if the family had
started over at that point with no
further genealogy to pursue so I
hypothesized and said let us say that
this is the person who converted to
Islam or possibly he converted to Islam
in this and or he's the father the one
who converted to Islam in anyway let's
say that that's that's the time the
point in that families geology where
conversion took place now since it's
let's say if you have a date of the life
of this person then you count the number
of generations going back and you
multiply by a standard figure for the
length of a generation and you can
deduce our induce you can determine the
average length of a generation by taking
a large number of samples in which you
know the death date of a father and the
death date of a son and you can subtract
of the the former from the ladder and
you discover how long was the gap
between a person's being born and the
death of of his father when you do that
you get a number of about 35 years now
that seems too old in the sense that we
think of people having siring children
somewhat younger but you have to allow
for the fact that that with plural
marriage a man of that period could sire
children over a substantial sequence of
years and that the 35 would be the
midpoint of that sequence the youngest
child might have been sired when he was
25 the oldest when he was 50 or
something like that but in any case it's
simply a standard term used for the
length of a generation but if you do
that
you say here's the time of this person's
life then you can say let's say this is
the time the second persons like time a
third person's life that's the time of
the person who converted to Islam it's
it's clearly an approximation of all
generations not the same length we don't
have data about these individuals other
than then the first one all we have is a
name Mark Twain and his book on life in
the Mississippi has a wonderful line
where he says you know science is such
is so wonderful you you reap such a
harvest of conjecture for such a tiny
input of fact but if you have a large
number of genealogies that fit this
pattern let's say you know four or five
hundred genealogies that follow an a a a
a P pattern then you can look at the at
the the time for the reported date of
conversion and you can add up those
times and distribute them over a over
time scale so
let's say here is a time scale that goes
in the case of Islam who would go from
say 622 the beginning of the Islamic
calendar up as far as you want to go for
Christianity and would start at 0 go up
as far as you want to go for Buddhism
let's say start - 500 BCE goes up as far
as you want to go you know the point of
generative genesis of the religion if
it's a religion that is going to another
place it may be that what you know is
the first instance of the religion in
that place rather than the first
occurrence so that we there's a general
agreement that the first Buddhist known
to have come from China to China from
India and to have brought with them a
knowledge of the Buddhist faith arrived
live somewhere around 65
seee which is just about the beginning
of when the term Christian comes first
to be used for the followers of Jesus so
this is the synchrony you get between
Buddhism in China and Buddhism in the
Roman Empire
even though Buddhism is much older in in
India now if you if you add all of these
all of these dates what you get
is a curve like that and this is known
to statisticians as a logistic curve
what it is is the integral of a
bell-shaped just standard distribution
curve as to say that if you were to add
everything in t1 to everything in t2 to
everything in t3 you wouldn't get it
tapering off because you're adding
everything and so it it adds up to an
s-shaped curve logistic curve now the
fact that this is related to a standard
distribution curve is suggestive it
suggests that there is probability
involved in other words the whole point
of a standard distribution curve is that
things are at their greatest level of
probability at the peak of the curve and
as you move down either arm it becomes
less and less probable and you measure
this probability by standard deviation
so this would be one standard deviation
from the mean on one side one standard
would be other time so forth we don't go
into that right now but the point is
that when it turned out that the real
data I was using from genealogies fit
this curve it had it was a very very
suggestive finding but it wasn't
suggestive to me because I had never
heard of a logistic curve I was teaching
at Berkeley at the time I gave a talk
about what I was finding about
genealogies I drew this curve and
afterwards a geographer in the audience
said that's a very interesting use of
the logistic curve and I said let me
write down this word logistic and where
can I find out something about it cuz I
had never heard
of logistic curve and I know nothing
about statistics I ended up having to go
to library and check out a couple of
text books on statistics and teach
myself something about it but it turned
out that the logistic curve was not only
a known way of looking at distribution
of something but it was used over and
over and over and over again to study
diffusion all sorts of things have been
measured in their diffusion of
popularity by logistic curves indeed it
is a pillar of the of the marketing
science industry now to predict the rate
and to try and influence the rate of
spread of a new product it has literally
been used thousands of times in the 20th
century to model the actual rate of
diffusion of something and to predict
the probable rate of diffusion of
something because it is such a reliable
instrument
it's used by epidemiologists in a
somewhat different way used by
demographers in a somewhat different way
but it's one of the most common
statistical instruments for for the
study of the spread of things in the
20th century it just that nobody had
ever applied it to the study of religion
so I thought is it possible that the
adoption of religion is like the
adoption of hybrid corn that it is
something that spreads by the same you
know quantifiable pattern that would be
applied to two instances of
technological innovation when I actually
sent my book in to a publisher they sent
it to a professional a prophets Oriole
reviewer who wrote back reviews saying
that it is so basically it is so
insulting
for somebody to apply marketing theory
to religion that this book should never
be published and I had to go through the
letter of the scathing review and I
broke it down into 36 specific hostile
arguments then I had to go through and
refute every one of them largely on the
basis of what was in the book I said
well if this reviewer had read page 26
he would have realized why are these fun
of it or he read page 42 he would have
realized already fun of that but but he
hated it because as I said people who
are interested in conversion tend to be
people of faith and people who were
interested in in diffusion tend to be
people who are interested in things and
the question the relationship of things
to faith is a is a vexed one
nevertheless the data word were clear
I had a genuine logistic curve derived
directly from from empirical data
preserved in medieval sources and I was
going to go with my data and then see
what I could get how was the
the coincidence between the curve I
derived empirically and the theories
involved with the curve now it turns out
there's fundamentally one underlying
theory and it is the theory that unites
the world of of faith or the world of
the intellect and the world of things
and that is communication because
fundamentally what this is is a curve
based on the dissemination of
information you start out with a handful
of people who contact a somewhat larger
handful of people and convince some
subset of them to adopt a new thing but
there's hybrid corn or a new faith those
people contact others persuade a few of
them to adopt something new and you get
what in physics you would call a chain
reaction where each generation produces
a larger base than the one before and
that produces a large number of converts
and then if what's get an example and it
diminishes because you've saturated the
audience for example if you're
converting people you know here in the
beginning you're plenty of pagans around
you know you cross the street and you
run into fifteen pagans but by the time
you get to here you can't find a pagan
because almost everybody is converted
but the same thing would would apply if
you were adopting a new you know hybrid
corn to begin with nobody's using it
then a few people use it and then pretty
soon everybody's using it so it seemed
to me that at the level of communication
theory this made a great deal of sense
but it challenged the hypothesis that
charisma is at the center
of conversion because it's just
particularly if you're talking about
preliterate societies in which there is
no way of amplifying the voice or
recording the voice there is simply a
physical limit to how many people a
missionary could have come into contact
with and so if the Christians say saint
willy broad went to Frisia and the
Frisians converted to christianity under
his guidance you think how many Frisians
actually sold saint willy bird or is
this simply a shorthand saying he was
the first and then it proceeded by other
processes what would the other processes
be now if you if you break it down to to
the question of communication then you
look into the literature on innovation
diffusion the 20th century particularly
at the marketing end of it and you find
that there's a great deal of study of
why do people adopt something new it's a
rather sophisticated view you know say
right now if you go to hulu to look at a
TV show and an ad will show up sometimes
hopital's say would you rather see an ad
based on the testimonial or would you
rather see an ad based on on scientific
evidence or something that you know that
they're still trying to decide what it
is that makes people adopt things the
most common of you I think it's still
the most common view is that people
adopt things because some of they know
is adopted it not someone they know
simply casually it's not you know
because the doorman in the building has
adopted it it's because the adoption has
been made by someone they know and
esteem that they know and trust this is
why you have
thousands of television advertisements
that are many dramas of this model of
adoption where someone's young a woman
comes into the kitchen and says you know
Veronica how do you get George's
underwear so clean said well mom I use
new blue cheer usually holding it on her
shoulder which is not the place most
people will hold a new product but it's
the one that gets the 2-shot between the
product of the face of the adopters
oh that's wonderful your blue blue chair
or I am a pharmacist and when I have a
problem with erectile dysfunction not
now I take Cialis we all you're supposed
to trust it now you know that he's not a
pharmacist and you know that that was
not a mother-in-law and a
daughter-in-law talking you know that it
is a completely fictional drama written
by an ad person but it is intended to
model the status relations that are felt
to be the most influential factors in
causing people to adopt new things which
leads to the question of do people adopt
new religions because of a charismatic
figure that they that they've heard
about the power perhaps even seen once
or because someone they know has adopted
them the suggestion of the logistic
curve is that it is the spread of
communication the spread of information
rather than the fortuitous encounter
with a saintly figure or a missionary
that is the the crucial thing that
people
you know move into a faith community
from their old faith community because
they know someone who has already done
it it's very likely a family member or
someone who is a leader in the community
we can even find examples that sort of
suggest that people knew this where
you'll have a the son of a of a
religious figure or perhaps of a royal
family who is targeted for conversion on
the grounds that well if the son of the
bishop converted to Islam then that must
be a good thing and I'll convert to
Islam or if the prince has adopted
Christianity I should not Christianity
because we revere that so it's all
affected by the social structure and the
status relations that you have within a
particular society but here that you're
dealing with the there are the
likelihood is that this kind of curve
works better for pre modern intellectual
trendin sees than modern lives simply
because printing and then electronic
dissemination of information make the
whole timetable of the spread of
information so much faster that it's
harder to to pin it down but when you're
safely ensconced in the late ancient
world you know that you're dealing with
something that where communication
simply can't be very fast you also have
the complication that it's very hard to
learn about something new from someone
who does not tell you about it in your
own language so another factor here is
what are the languages that are in use
and when do you first have people who
are able to communicate in the language
of the target audience as opposed to the
initial language of the faith for Islam
it's a question of since array Arabic
was only spoken in the Arabian Peninsula
along the desert fringes north of Arabia
most of the areas that the Arabs spread
into did not speak Arabic so how could
Islam spread through communication if
the people who are the Muslims couldn't
speak the language of the people who
were the potential converts for
Christianity we assume that aramaic was
the language of the earliest community
and probably st. Peter and the the
disciples who remained in Jerusalem
after the crucifixion they are probably
primarily Aramaic speakers now think of
Paul Paul spoke Greek some of the other
disciples spoke Greek as well and have
Greek names but but you have to assume
that for those people who were Greek
speakers encountering a Aramaic speaking
missionary would have done no good now
you can say well okay let's look at
translations but again there you have
the problem that that that it presumes a
literacy and most people were not
literate so when you look at the spread
of information you have to look at the
at the the status relations in the
society who is likely to have been
sources of emulation for people who are
joining a new religion and you have to
look at the of the means of
communication
it's one thing to have a missionary come
from a foreign land but he doesn't speak
your language it doesn't do a whole lot
of good ah
now what I'm leaving out here is is the
particular religion appealing as so much
of the study of the spread of faith is
focused on the doctrines rather than on
the the process that in many cases the
doctrines seem to have been over over
read in the sense that too much has been
read into issues of doctrine for example
you'll find many Christian writers who
say that Islam spreads in Africa because
Islam permits plural marriage and
African men like to have a lot of women
that's basically racist I don't think
even beyond basically I think it's
explicitly racist but that's past a
scholarly wisdom in lots of books and
it's highly implausible unless you
actually have data that relate to the
frequency of plural marriage and so
forth and so on all men cannot have
numerous wives there aren't enough women
for every man that has numerous wives
there's some poor guy who's kind of you
know hanging out by himself in his
bedroom at night and you know not
enjoying that particular privilege Oh
so doctrines tend to be over rib but
more importantly what constitutes the
doctrine is a variable and to me this
was one of the most striking conjectures
that I can't that I drew from the
itty-bitty bit of information I actually
had about Islam and conversion and that
was that what Islam was changed as a
function of the dissemination of the
information and the growth of the
community and what the religions were
from which people were converting to
Islam that changed as well and this has
to do with the sense of whether you are
in a minority or whether you're in a
majority when people study this kind of
curve in talking about innovation
diffusion in the 20th century in other
words when they're looking at how
something becomes popular what they do
is they divide it into the divide the
curve into segments the curve in flex of
the 50% point and become symmetrical on
either side of it and the divisions as I
mentioned our division 222 standard
deviation
one two three four standard deviations
to the left or to the right of the mean
now what this means is it has it has to
do with probability in other words it is
you know phenomenally in improbable that
anyone was going to adopt the religion
at this point because the religion was
barely known
the chances of you actually encountering
someone who could explain it to your own
language
we're very slim but then it starts to
grow and you have a few more and more
and then you get a bandwagon effect over
the period from the from one standard
deviation to the left to one strand
deviation to the right of the mean you
have a massive amount of conversion or a
massive amount of adoption of a new of a
new process or a new product modern a
modernization theorists give names to
these categories pioneers change agents
etc because what they're trying to do is
to identify social categories that have
the highest or the lowest propensity to
adopt something new the highest or the
lowest likelihood of being persuaded to
do something new you know think well how
can you do that how can you how can you
guess who is likely to to do something
new well one thing you can guess at is
that you know if you're real old you're
probably not going to do something new
you know what you do thank you and you
know actually you don't particularly
want to to buy a Segway and and learn
how to travel on two wheels you can't
get your Walker for example to to
balance on it so that's one category
you'll be category in the young category
the old when you look at the demographic
models that you see in advertising you
can see how marketing people aim at
selling to particular particular age
cohorts I don't have to give examples I
go to
it's pretty obvious there are some
things that you said I mean nobody sells
depends to young people it's uh you know
there are things are so lonely to old
people but in the broader sense of how
are these categories defined in the case
of adoption of a new product or process
the key has always been advantage you
know material return the first people
who do something our thought of as the
ones who are getting the benefit the
greatest benefit that's the reason some
other people are persuaded to do what
they're doing so they see the benefit
other words with a new process or a new
product the change agents the innovators
are seen as the first to to take
advantage of something that benefits
them they can now communicate more
easily because they have a you know a 4G
phone or they can travel easier they can
you know jump higher because they have a
new running shoe that is balanced on
helium balloons or something there's it
there's an advantage now the advantage
diminishes as you work up the scale
because pretty soon everybody has the
same advantage but at the innovative
stage that can be important in other
words the first person of hybrid corn
may have a larger crop and sell it for
more money and he gets rich so the model
of innovation diffusion when it comes to
the material world has tended to be that
the people who adopt something first are
youngish people who are well educated
who have the resources to
to risk making a mistake who have the
the social contacts for them to hear
about something new and they get
substantial rewards for having been in
first on a new trend this is paralleled
by other people who are poor have few
resources are out of touch have little
information and they are the laggards
they are the ones who are going to come
along at the end of the curve so the the
big takeaway lesson of innovation
diffusion in the 20th century has been
the rich get rich and the poor get
poorer
no big surprise we are we already do
that now
you take it over to ideological change
in this case religion to become a
Buddhist to give a Christian to become a
Muslim is there a real world advantage
the doctrinally you could say to become
a Christian or become a Muslim less so
become a Buddhist means that your chance
of going to paradise is increased but
you know that's a long shot you you
really don't know about the payoff until
it's too late to change your mind
now you die you go to heaven you hope or
you see heaven from outside the gate and
you say oh my god they're talking Hebrew
you know what a mistake I learn Latin or
I speak Arabic and and you realize the
way it was like so so so even though
even though you have religions that are
salvation all the salvation is a gamble
rather than a sort of thing
economic payoff yes absolutely there are
certainly cases where there is an
economic pay off but that pay off tends
to be to people who are poor rather than
people who are rich it's different from
the from the pay off from from material
innovation because typically the the
financial benefits by people convert to
an ore we load religion are best
realized by people who are come in at a
service level well becomes an cooks or
drivers or something like that they you
know there's no easy way to come in as a
bishop unless of course you're already a
welding senator then you can convert
become a bishop right away so in some
cases the rich do get Richard it may be
that there are circumstances in which
you enter the new religion because
you're compelled you know there is a
battle you lose you survive now you are
a slave and then you're told
Oh in this faith if you convert to the
new religion you'll be freed and you'll
no longer be a slave of course you'll
still have to work for your former
master all your days will be as client
but nevertheless you will not be a slave
so sometimes your material advantages if
it's a conquering situation you may be
that if you join the army that just
defeated you and that army goes on to
win other victories you will share in
the loot that is gained in other
victories so there may be material
banners of that sort you have to look at
specific cases and see how they work but
on the whole when you look at at
populations globally instead of at very
specific groups such as those who are in
combat situations or
slavery situations or situations where
they move from one elite status to
another it's hard to to generalize in
this way I use two things that I call
axioms to to try and make sense of what
happens when people change religious
faith and there may be others these are
two that have occurred to me and I call
them axioms because I can't possibly
defend them and if somebody wants to
write a paper refuting them that's just
fine but one of them is that no one
voluntarily converts from religion a to
religion B if by conversion he or she
markedly lowers his social status if you
have a religion of slaves and the
emperor converts to it the Emperor does
not become a slave but it now becomes a
religion of emperors you you know people
do not trade down in the area of
religion now what they consider to be
trading up can vary in other words you
may feel you're trading up if you join
the religion of a new ruling group but
you also may feel you're trading up if
you join a religion that has a you know
a written scripture and religious
edifices of some sort and you're moving
from a sort of an unscriptural
preliterate tribal faith to something
more sophisticated your notion of what
is is making a better can be a variable
the second axiom is that people who are
who change religion generally have the
same expectations of religion or the
same hopes of what their religion may
produce for them in the new religion
that they have in the old religion in
other words people are not really reborn
in a new religion rather they bring
their their hopes and their expectations
from the old religion to the new
religion so that if you come from a
religion that has a say a panoply of
ritual activities you'll expect a
panoply original activities come from a
religion that has an elaborated legal
system you'll expect a legal system if
you come from a religion that has a an
authority structure so that everybody
knows who is the the bishop or who is
the abbot of the monastery then you will
expect to have that kind of authority
structure it also means that when you
have new religions say the case of Islam
or for that matter the case of
Christianity the case of Buddhism in
China it means that when people enter
the religion entering with them is a
large corpus of a belief and tradition
and societal and institutional
expectation that they had in their
previous religion and that changes the
religion to which they're converted so
if you have a religion that has no law
and is practiced by you know
50,000 conquerors and you move down the
line and pretty soon you have the
descendants of those 50,000 conquerors
plus 4 million converts who have
converted from a faith background that
has an elaborate law system the religion
of those initial 50,000 will will
produce a legal system because the
converts want a legal system they will
demand a legal system and this is the
reason the religion changes over time
you also have the phenomenon many people
when they think about religious change
think new converts are fanatics they're
zealots but that is it true that is true
at this end of the curve when you have
people who are standing out for their
earliness in a process it doesn't apply
to people that under the curve who are
old fogies who are getting on a
bandwagon that actually passed some time
ago and they're just kind of dragging
along and getting on it but what it
means is that often a new religion has
to have something that appeals to people
who are religiously zealous and who find
their their existing religion
unsatisfactory you know I want to be
saved
and Christianity isn't doing it for me
so I'll join us LOM and get saved there
frequently this is unsatisfactory
someone converts someone who's really
zealous converts from from one religion
to another stays in that religion for a
while and then converts on to a third
religion or go a fourth religion these
people are like all serial converts what
they like is the emotional
charge they get each time they convert
each time they think now it's the real
thing and now they enough the model of
the serial convert is st. Augustine who
is so excited when he discovers
neoplatonism and he's a plate honest
Platonism doctrines play till they
explain everything in the world but here
the manikyam faith so now the manikyam
faith this dualism for me Ron this is
the is the real deal
I'll become a manichaean it will explain
everything but you know actually
Christianity is better so now quit big
amount of key and I'll become a
Christian so it goes a Christian and
then after what point says you know
Christianity is fine but what a mystical
Christianity be better and I hear a
small boys here in the garden and it's
God talking to me so now I'm a mystic
serial convert SAR occur in many
situations but over time they're not the
ones in particular who will galvanize
the middle of the curve its ordinary
people who who change in the middle of
the curve and among the laggards you get
very little zealot tree but the religion
has to develop to provide room for dull
you know phlegmatic older people to
convert it can't always be a religion of
zealots it has to adapt so that
depending on the proportion that you
have in the society the the character of
the religion changes and when you look
at the history of Christianity or the
history of Buddhism of history of Islam
you see these changes and historians of
religion will note phases in the history
of religious communities but they don't
always a soap about how they rarely
associate them with changes in the in
the dominance within the society of the
of the believers in this
faith now this is a time scale and let's
say this is a percentage scale in which
you're talking about the percent of of
the community that that ever converts to
the religion there is a a group at the
top that consists of people who never
convert if you were in the epidemiology
using this curve you would say these are
the immune population that simply never
you know never can never will catch a
certain disease in religious situations
there's always a certain percentage that
that never joined the new religion and
it's very difficult ever to gauge how
many there are but but you know that
they that they are there I note that
Druidism has just been recognized as a
legitimate religion in England and who
knew the Druids were still around the
the time scale is something that can be
graphed very clearly from the data and
then you can see that the logistic curve
has certain mathematical properties that
actually allow you to to take any two
points on the curve and generate the
entire curve you can say this curve that
I had for iran is derived from specific
empirical information that I collected
and massaged in a not very reliable
fashion and but I produced a real curve
out of real information but then once I
had the curve I could say all I need is
two points on the curve and I can
generate the equation for the curve as a
whole or if I'm dealing with another
situation where I don't have
quantifiable information if I have two
points on a curve I can generate the
process of conversion so so a lot in
this congestus conjecture
rides on the idea that that the the the
sort of the geometric expansion of
information how to say that the
communication feature is so central to
the process of ideological change in
this case religious change that we can
assume that at least some cases
we we can postulate let us assume that
there is a logistic curve at work here
even though we don't have empirical
quantifiable material it would prove
that there's a little just a curve do we
have two points and if you have two
points can is it legitimate to draw a
curve and say this is the rate of growth
this is the pattern of growth of let's
say Christianity in the Roman Empire or
the pattern of growth of Buddhism in
China now I noted that there seems to be
you know a similar rate of growth of
Christianity and of Buddhism but can you
actually measure it more precisely now
historians of Christianity have actually
tried to come up with hard numbers for
specific dates and they've done it from
from scriptural sources and other you
know at least quasi documentary sources
and they have said in the year 200 CE II
during the Roman Empire it appears that
there were 10,000 Christians in the
Roman Empire and this almost counting
noses mean you know city by city you
figure out how many people were in each
Christian self what places did have
Christianity what places did you not
10000 Christians in the year 200 given a
ballpark assumption that the Roman
Empire had a population of about 60
million
gives you a percentage of 0.03 percent
Christians in 200 then other historians
have said in the year 300 which is just
before Constantine declares Christianity
to be the official religion of the
Empire at least part of the Empire that
he rules in the east in 300 there appear
to be 10% of the Roman population is
Christian
that is to say out of 60 million people
6 million are Christians in the year 300
alright so here if you have 100 200 300
400 500 600 etc now you have a data
point here the data point here and you
can now write an equation that will give
you the curve for the growth of
Christianity and their own Empire so and
you know you're hypothesizing us we'll
just occurred and so you you end up with
that you say is that likely to have been
the actual pattern of growth of
Christianity of the Roman Empire you
don't have the data to prove it on the
other hand you can look at it and say
does it appear to be reasonable does
that appear to be likely now when I
worked on the Islamic world that
ultimately was the test the whole theory
was was a heuristic one had to say a
theory that was meant to to teach a
lesson rather than to assert a truth now
I thought it asserted a truth
but then it was my theory and there was
absolutely no way to test them no I had
taken a certain number of genealogies
I'd handled them a certain way but there
was no alternative quantitative measure
against which to test the curve that I
have produced so I said it's it's not a
certainty but can we learn something
from it
and it turned out there were certain
things you could learn for example once
you pass the 50% point central
government disappears because to the
degree that central government was
predicated on the other idea of
protecting Muslims in a largely
non-muslim environment once the
environment becomes all Muslim who needs
to have an army sent out from Baghdad
before 50% you had people who would have
revolts against Islam after 50% people
have revolts within Islam so in many
ways the curve that I came up with that
showed that the bandwagon period of
conversion to Islam at least in the East
and say her Iran and Iraq was say
between 200 and 300 years after the
beginning of the Islamic calendar as say
between 2 and and 300 of the hijra it
turned out that that fit a very large
array of political and institutional and
doctrinal developments in the medieval
Islamic world
what has happened over the years is that
I'd say most historians medieval Islam
now follow the chronology that I
developed but do not adopt the
methodology that produced the chronology
they say well if it makes the most sense
of anybody's chronology but it's a
screwball way of having gotten it well
fine
let them carve now if you but if you do
it for the Roman Empire then what do you
get if you have a number for two hundred
number three hundred you extrapolate the
curve instead of finding that the that
it is between 200 and 300 years after
the inception of Islam that you get the
bandwagon period you find those between
three and four hundred years in
Christianity and that in order to get
pretty much to the climax of the curve
for the old Roman Empire that is to say
the the eastern part instead of taking
four hundred years as it does with Islam
later on it takes about six hundred
years then you can start to correlate
that you could say well when did you
have the last emperor who wanted to
revive paganism and so you have Julian
the apostate will come down around here
because after that challenges are not
against Christianity but they're rather
within Christianity the development of
legal concerns is paralleled at similar
points on the curve between Islam and
Christianity and there there are
numerous other things that you could
look at for correlation so this is a
theory that would argue that the growth
of Christianity despite the fact that it
becomes official in 300 that the growth
of Christianity is greatest between four
and five hundred rather than between
zero and
300 and that therefore Christianity is a
largely post the decay of the of the
Roman Empire particularly in the West in
the East the Empire remains more more
valid I'll talk about that in a later
lecture
now my guess is that this kind of
logistic expansion would work for China
as well and that you my guess is that
even though I have no numbers for China
that it probably took let us say before
but between four and six hundred years
something parallel to put together
Islamic Christianity for China to become
predominantly Buddhist and that the
period of the greatest growth of
Buddhism was almost certainly after the
fall of the Han Dynasty which occurs in
221 a CCE so then you get you get this
question of you know is there something
about the the end of the empire that
conduces toward people finding a
personal stance with respect to faith to
be particularly appealing now I don't
know what the answer of it is except
that it is striking to my mind that
today in the midst of our globalization
you have an accompanying belief on the
part of vast numbers of people that our
civilization is falling apart very
rapidly and you have an enormous growth
in various parts of the world and highly
personalized commitments to faith and no
you just have to wonder is this a broad
phenomenon in which there is a
relationship between a highly
personalised faith and a sense of
of decay or or chaos the setting the
primary institutions of society or is
this simply a curious way to to end a
lecture